all right all this week we've been
exploring the world of weddings looking
at the very different ways people get
married and celebrate their love around
the globe Seth Doane travel to Israel
where he met a same-sex couple who had
to find a legal loophole to get their
marriage recognized there this has all
of the trappings traditions and
excitement of a wedding but gay marriage
is not legal here in Israel Israel
embraces gay tourists and hosts a gay
pride but lags behind when it comes to
gay rights still hundreds of wedding
guests have gathered in a very public
show of support their celebration was no
doubt different the venue was a
nightclub and the officiant was not a
rabbi but they wanted to keep some of
the classic Jewish traditions the toasts
the giant hoop up or canopy representing
halls and the stomping on glasses
[Applause]
I think that just by doing a big wedding
in Israel that's that's our big
statement not letting the system take
you down
Iran buk knee and mayor stern met almost
a decade ago when they were serving in
Israel's army do you think it was love
at first sight we were with them ahead
of the big day as they checked out the
venue the decorations and those
all-important details at their Tel Aviv
apartment we heard how the stresses of
planning a wedding or Universal hasn't
always been a peaceful situation or have
there been argued but as a same-sex
couple there were considerable
differences in wedding planning
[Music]
[Applause]
the Tel Aviv celebrations were actually
part two of the wedding back in August
the guys and their families traveled to
Portugal where they could legally marry
then a loophole allows the Union to be
officially recognised in Israel in 2018
more than 400 same-sex couples
registered their foreign weddings here
etai Pincus a Tod was among the first
same-sex couples to marry outside of the
country he's on the City Council and
founded Tel Aviv's LGBT Center which
staged a mass wedding protest during
Pride in June we wanted to give an
opportunity for as many couples as
possible to get kind of married married
from a publicity respective more than a
legal one Israel's pride is a
destination for gay travelers but this
is a Jewish state and Pinkus Arad said
the religious Orthodox pose a party
opposition being gay is a sin in Judaism
it's yes against the Jewish law
[Music]
dear marriage is a religious institution
there's no civil union straight or gay
in tel-aviv
you have gay parties you have gay pubs
and bars but sometimes it feels as if
like the government is using tel-aviv or
the gay community as like pink wash what
is a pink club showing to the world Oh
Israel is a very liberal place and where
Israel is very accepting because when
you compare it to the other countries of
the Middle East yeah it's right still
they're proud of their country and their
relationship we want all of our friends
and families to be there and to keep the
Jewish tradition and at their ceremony
Liron and Maor selected the rainbow as
their wedding colors I like your hair
here something may ORS mom incorporated
right into her hairdo you didn't need to
know Hebrew to understand the connection
between the families are you feeling
[Laughter]
just after the vows the guys changed
into t-shirts for a brother-sister
family dance-off
this wedding everything you hope for
yeah during the ceremony I was like
looking at the crowd I said I have to
memorize this picture of all the people
we know and all of the people we love
standing together at the same place and
it's amazing the legalities or lack
thereof are overlooked here at least for
this celebratory moment we're all that
matters is love for CBS this morning
Seth Doane Tel Aviv thank you very much
Seth well whether it's recognized by the
state or not it looked like a lot of fun
yeah did it does seem a pink wash I
guess that was what he called it right
that they support gay tourism but not
gay marriage yeah this is a divide that
goes way back to the founding of the
state the religious community controls
weddings and then secular community
controls other things I'm still playing
itself out all right so thank you very
much